welcome to another edition of technology
tuesday and today i mentioned a question
from
troy one of my youtube viewers love you
guys who's asking about
evernote so troy's question was nice
video a couple of questions
does the photo taken from the phone take
up more space than the scanned pdf
do you ever take photos of eight and a
half by eleven invoices receipts and so
on
or are those better scanned this is a
great question and when you're using
evernote you can either get a scan snap
or a scanner that can connect to
evernote or you can take pictures with
your phone
and i used to do everything scanning and
now i use
the phone mostly for convenience so in
terms of the sizing to answer your
question
i found that by keeping approximately
the same setting so they get the same
quality of image if you take a picture
with your phone it's gonna be five
times bigger than if you scan it through
a scan stamp which is what i use as my
scanner
so it does take up a lot more space
about five times bigger the second thing
to think about is if you use a scanner
with my scan snap it will straighten the
paper as it goes through so if you have
any creases or folds or bends in your
receipt
and maybe you've folded in your wallet
or you know your agreement was
crippled at the side the scanner will
flatten it out as it goes through the
scanning process
where with a phone you have to stomp it
out and make it flat
yourself so if you have a lot of folded
papers you want to use the scanner
and the other thing i found that when
you scan documents in
it's easier to take it back to stores so
if you are going to
return something right you bought
something at ikea you want to take it
back
they're much more willing to accept a
scanned version then a picture of a
receipt for whatever reason
and i guess one last thing when you're
taking a picture with your phone you
have to make sure that it's
focused so some of the early ones that i
took i would just take a picture
and then throw away the receipt and then
realize that when i looked at it on my
computer it was out of focus
and it couldn't pick up the text
recognition so it made it a lot harder
so there's a lot of reasons why to use
the scan snap scan instead of taking a
phone
having said that i still do everything
on the phone
and the main reason is convenience it's
just a lot faster
than putting things through the scanner
so i'll i'll lay out all the receipts on
the floor
or on the table or whatever it is and
just go snap snap snap snap snap snap
snap snap
and save it and they're all there so yes
you have to make sure they're flat
yes you have to make sure you know the
camera is in focus
yes it's going to be bigger on your
computer than uh
than scanning it in but i find that it
saves you some time so hopefully that
helps great question
for those of you watching you like the
video you can subscribe to the channel
uh you can support me by clicking on the
link in the description and
leave a comment you have a question
whatever note you have a comment about
this video leave it below
and love seeing those comments so thank
you and i'll see you soon